[Music]
happy Friday everybody and welcome to et
life thank you for tuning in I have a
reality TV icon here with me mama June
Shannon round of applause in the studio
[Applause]
thank you for being here with us tonight
on the eve of the premiere of season 2
from not too hot tonight on WE tv 9:00
8:00 central how excited are you about
getting a second season I'm pretty
excited I'm now it's like all the
medical things would like me losing
weight it's over with now people get to
the back to the fun side the whole
family what's going on and a lot has
changed since first season so I think
they are gonna be very surprised it's
gonna be emotional rollercoaster these
next eight 8 episodes really yeah
emotional rollercoaster well kind of
what we see throughout the season I
think is Alana honey boo boo has become
your pageant coach the tables have
turned is why does she not do pageants
anymore um honestly it's more busy with
life it's not the fact that she doesn't
want to get Mike Intimus it's like with
everything we're on production school
just life in general it just gets hard
and pageants are a lot of work and so
she Lobo caught me doing something crazy
do you see her doing pageants again in
the future maybe and I think it is her
way of saying okay I want to get back
into it okay now we're seeing an
emotional roller coaster like you said
you had the surgery you transformed your
body and now we're gonna kind of see the
next chapter of your life
so with transforming your body you have
daughters how has that changed the
conversation that you have with them
about their body um a lot of things they
wear on no greased diet and so she's
been actually doing pretty good with it
and so you know it is what she doesn't
eat like you know grease like fried
whatever and like she's trying to like
cut back on like soda so I'm really
really powering that something she did
not that I done oh wow okay well now by
the way you guys I have I mean
dozens of questions for Mom and Jun here
but we want to know your questions to
leave your comments leave your questions
I'm gonna get them here on our ETI pad
and I can ask this lovely lady so we'll
keep on diving in here so kind of
changed the way that their diets are as
well it sounds like is that because of
what you've learned about
your own body um yeah and nothing
they've like watched me so they're like
okay Lestrade okay so in changing her
diet has Alana seen any changes so she
lost well she's lost about 5 pounds so I
mean that's a huge accomplishment for
somebody you know what I mean
and it was for me I mean it doesn't you
put on the weight very easy but it's not
easy to come off a promise you know has
this journey been harder than you
thought it would be definitely has been
a lot harder and especially doing in the
public eye it's been kind of crazy
because who are like we're not the
nethers say I missed the old moment you
know I'm gonna say happy mama Jean and
it's like I'm still the same person like
it's no different how did you felt like
your personality has changed at all with
your body change um uh-huh
no definitely still the same person now
crazy
do you think that watching you go
through all this I mean have you had
different talks with Alana with pumpkin
like did they look at themselves
differently or does it make them think
about body image - pumpkin is way overly
confident she thinks she heard her new
hashtag is hot Teen Mom for 2018
ok no she just had a baby yes how do you
feel about that hashtag um ideas or
tears pumpkin is overconfident she
thinks she is like God's gift to women I
love women man whatever cuz how old is
pumpkin now she's trying to 18 this past
Sunday okay well happy birthday to her
and then you have a new grandbaby now
you had a baby are they living with you
what's this yes they live at our house
pretty much right now because of justice
traveling they've been able to do
suggested be able to spend time with is
Ellen and Josh and heard has been able
to spend time just at the house because
I've been on the road yeah unfortunately
not been able to spend a lot of time at
home well you guys are like it takes a
village when you have a new baby
comments coming in just compliments for
you mike says mom and jr. looking great
nikki says OMG you look amazing thank
you
alright now I love that pumpkin has that
confidence and that you do I think
you're so good at instilling confidence
in your girls but you know with putting
Alana on that diet like are you worried
about their health is that part of why
um you know I mean I am worried about
their health because I don't want them
to go through what I went through you
know I mean and like I said so many
people put judge um people and they
sweat so much on body image you know
what I mean and I'm like come on out
it's not about what your body
you know I mean I was healthy you know I
mean I don't have any medical issues so
for me doing it I did it for myself and
you have to do it for yourself for him
for most when you say you were healthy
do you mean before or after the surgery
before the surgery I was I was honestly
healthy I didn't do it for health
reasons I did it because I wanted to so
you didn't have and I didn't know that
you didn't have any health issues the
surgery no okay
so with Alana and is are you thinking of
a next phase for he said no Greece diet
no soda what's next um you know whatever
it is I'm a supporter you know I'm
saying and I didn't push into doing it
she chose to do it herself so I just
want her to continue on to doing
whatever makes her happy you know what I
mean and that's just the way that I've
always been whatever makes you happy
big small medium large you know you got
to love yourself form form of this
period so true now we have seen you go
through this journey and I think you
told us recently you've gained a little
bit of weight back about 10 pounds over
the last year and I've especially over
like I'd have to say like in the last
few months it is with everything going
on and the holidays and everything else
it's just you can't you know I'm saying
in 10 pounds in a year and a half that's
not to me not bad what's been the key to
you sticking to this diet to keeping
that weight off knowing that I'll never
go back to what I was before within my
mom yeah just that mental stress yes you
have to I think it's hard everybody
deals with food food such an emotional
thing I mean I deal with it I think we
all do I where they found that strength
for me food when I get stressed out I
don't eat so I'm not like a stress eater
at all for the most part but I like to
snack you know I'm saying I'm bad about
snacking on like a little cube cheese or
like grapes or you know stuff like that
so it's kind of like that's my that's my
weakness no got it you watch it your
favorite TV show yes Zach I know so what
about your overall goals you said you've
gained a little bit of weight back do
you want to see yourself hit a certain
number do you want to lose even more
weight I never know I'm happy with where
I'm at I mean I've kind of like leveled
out you know what I mean so for me I
kind of did never had a goal way to mine
and whatever it became of it came and I
knew I don't want to go over 170 and
that's my thing you know I mean I tried
to get out you know I'm saying it wasn't
like hey I want to go one said I know I
don't want to go over that so when I do
start going over that I start like
beating
self up and getting on the scale two and
three times a day and yes I know it's
not about the numbers but for me it is
yeah it's hard cuz you want to balance
being healthy not being focused on the
number but also you got to have some
goals that yes exactly yeah
so what about your surgeries because
you've had a couple of surgeries one of
you quite a few do you see yourself
doing any other surgeries no more
plastic surgery I'm done all I wanted to
do is my stomach my arms and that was it
and so I did those and I don't want to
apply the surgery I'm not gonna be
plastic and no fakeness or whatever what
you see is what you get what you see is
what you get so many comments coming in
for you so I don't want to miss them I
hope you're saying your name right god
says mama June since you eat healthy and
clean does your family still eat
roadkill
I must know PS you look great no we do
not a roadkill you can't do that in the
bouton city okay we've got that out of
the diet Kathy says that mom and June
what about a special person in your life
also you are looking great you do have a
guy in your life right how serious is
that very yeah very what is very mean
that's very mean marriage no no no
uh-huh
don't get interested don't get it
twisted no I said I mean we're very
committed to one another I would both
love each other very very happy in our
relationship we're both best friends
we're with each other 24/7 and it's just
happy you like both of us are very happy
with our life right now and each other
and the kids and so it just works like
we it's kind of strange like today being
away all day and you know we've been
tasting what everybody says kind of
strange and we're apart from each other
because we both take each other at the
same time the same message and it's kind
of just we just always have had that
connection and it's kind of like yes
nice okay hey I like seeing you smile
that I know you can't give away too much
because we're gonna see it really reveal
tonight he gets revealed tonight yes how
long have you known him um for a little
while we came from the same town we met
through mutual friends but we never
didn't know each other and actually I'm
only his second serious lection ship his
whole entire life Wow
so yes he liked holding out for you no
no no he was married for quite some time
so like I said I mean and so I look at
it this way he was committed you know
once before and so he's always in it for
the long haul and he's been incredible
the last you know six months with
everything going on and he's very
supportive he doesn't know have it
any idea who I was when I first met him
so that's kind of nice you don't give
two threats less about the cameras or
what's going on he's very friendly to
the fans and his life and you know
people in general so we just have a good
time we laugh be crazy people say that
we're both crazy together so we just it
is close I love that well why then no no
no on marriage no marriage ever again
for you
I never was married to begin with let's
clarify okay okay that's good to know
no never been married and so for me
Debbie's diaper doesn't change your love
or commitment for somebody and people
get that twisted sometimes and I can't I
love him just as much as I loved him
months ago you know I mean and so it's
just for me it's just for me just do it
like they like okay wait for the
honeymoon stage whatever but it's been
the honeymoon it feels like that every
day like I wake up to him and it's like
I smile
we both smile we you know saying it is
all right no you don't apologize I love
how you're gushing over him and we're
gonna meet him tonight on the premiere
love that now on the show that seems
like from what I've seen some of the
footage we do see you kind of slip on
your diet a little bit are we gonna see
that emotional journey for you when you
say roller coaster what is yeah I mean
it's his everything like from you know
pumpkin to me to just life in general I
think people are gonna be like okay
great we're back into their life it's
not just about her it's not just about
me it's about the whole family and I
think that's what people are gonna love
and be attracted to again and they're
gonna be like okay we're part of your
life and they can relate so what three
tips would you give somebody you've lost
so much weight what three tips would you
give somebody who's trying to lose
weight one don't do it for somebody else
you know I mean do it for yourself be in
it you know for the long haul
you know to don't ever give up I'm
saying I've thought about hey stick your
hands up give up and I think that make
realistic goals don't say okay I'm gonna
lose 20 pounds in a month and when you
don't lose but 15 don't get frustrated
that was so fast I love it mom and June
with the three tips just a lot more love
people saying you look so awesome and
she does we have we have awesome fans
people the husband our fans for many
many years they have went through the
struggles with me they have been
standing right beside me like they're
holding my hand and fans don't realize
how much that means to me of my family
no I love that did you a kind of
emotional about my fans do mean a lot
well you've had a lot of ups and downs
did you have unexpected issues because
of the surgeries no is's new issues that
are arising and I'm taking one day at a
time and Mahmoud you don't go nowhere so
don't worry about it huh I'm not I'm not
gonna kick the bucket or whatever so
that the young Sam but not right now but
like I said just take one day at a time
and try to find a silver lining just
kind of you know with the support of 1d
fans with my family and everybody around
me it just it helps well we see you in
some previous from the show in the
hospital I know Alana was there with you
and your new man was there with you was
there ever a moment when you were scared
for your life every day every day I mean
is it's just when I guess released y'all
understand because for me I've been
battling this for a minute and it came
on Barry this part came on very sudden
and this has been going on since like
July and it happened really fast
and so I've it's been a roller coaster
since July so this is not to do with the
surgeries but it's a health issue that
has you worried for your life every
single day um I would say for my life is
this my quality of lives let's put it
that way okay all right well I know I
know the fans are out there gonna
support you when they were and they're
finally able to figure out what's gonna
happen when are we gonna learn is that
gonna be tonight or not tonight probably
like in the next few episodes but it's
leading up to everything and trust me it
will be and I wish that I could share
with our fans killer fans know I'm so
personal but unfortunately okay
sometimes you can hey you got a watch
Joann wants to know will we be seeing
your other daughters on the show I know
you've had some estrangement with um
pumpkin will be on there Jessica's in
college Anna is back in Georgia but she
lives in South Georgia also you know and
it's gonna be like pumpkin Alana me and
that is all of it is right now how are
things with you and Anna cuz I know you
guys had your ups and downs she said you
owed her money she had an issue with a
guy you dated but I mean like I said I
mean we we talk every once in a while
and I had some struggles that she needs
to deal with herself and needs to stop
being I'm not trying to mean stop being
so selfish and it's not all about her
and I don't blame her for it is
a lot of other people that are around
her right now that kind of are
preventing stuff from happening so are
you guys talking regularly right now um
no not really here and there you know
what I mean and I do see Caitlin so you
know I do get to see her are you hopeful
that things with Ana will get better
what needs to happen um you know
honestly Ana needs to grow up and
realize that it's not all about her all
the time and you know this is real I
mean I'm saying yeah needs to realize
that she's 23 now and it's time to say
okay put my big girl pants on now well I
mean I'm sure as a mom this is hard for
you to talk to but just one last
question if there's anything you want to
set the record straight on cuz she did
say you know she said you owed her money
she said you dated this guy who didn't
treat her right who even you know well
we went through core that's like
personal matters I don't I don't a lot
of stuff like unfortunately I met on the
drama train like her and sugar bear and
my mom and my sister-in-law
I choose yourself on my own train that's
not drama and let them have the drama so
that's personal business and it was all
I said old so I know you try to share as
much as you can with your fans Deidre
says mom and June you are looking so
glam do you have a full glam squad what
do you do with that look I do not do
this unless I'm sitting here in front of
these interviews because a few kind of
miles my hair is in a bun like it is now
ain't all beautified up though and no
makeup like no no keep it real do you
feel sexier now I mean I know you you've
said this body has been a lot to adjust
to when have you felt sexiest um I don't
know I don't consider myself as like
both of them say see I'm because I don't
dress provocative so I guess sexiness
comes from addressing provocative in
some way well we saw you posing that
lingerie shoot that was pretty sexy yes
I've actually teamed up with that lon
and well I've known that lady for quite
some times we've opened up opened a club
with her in Palma Beach and then she
ended up doing the in essence clothing
line which all the clothes that I've
been wearing here lately have been her
lawn and we've teamed up together and so
anything that you see me wearing or
carnival I was very very affordable very
cheap so I um
I did that with Tonya Ryan and she's out
of Orden she's awesome what did it feel
like to pose in lingerie after the
surgery
seeing me on the Internet
it was kind of like like like I don't
regret it because I feel like if you
regret something you shouldn't it before
then it's like it's just kind of like
strange like like is that really me yeah
yeah yeah kind of thing would you ever
posed nude no no I was already offered
like over a million dollars to do a
porno and i said-
really hey okay what have you ever been
offered to pose nude um a few times been
negative I believe my clothes on why is
that because it's disrespect to have
kids and you know I mean I don't know I
don't think I have like the perfect body
okay well I think you look great but we
will not be seeing the mama June naked
no no no Lynn says sugar bear must be
kicking himself because you look so good
hmm I don't really care what she was
doing um as long as he stays out of my
hair and away from my house and my
family well let me ask you about that
cuz we do seem in previews he is on the
show
you've even called him physically and
mentally abusive Iran Ilana has went
public like that it's a healing process
for the kids it's been gone for quite a
bit it was covered up with the other
show it was covered up for many many
years and so I'm glad that people are
able to see the true side of sugar bear
that's been covered up for years and now
the girls are able to like heal from it
probably took a lot of the abuse and
that's why when that situation happened
that it was it's horrible for her and
when you've seen him go after her and so
for now is the girls able to heal
through this so this is kind of like a
healing process also for them mm-hmm so
we'll see that healing process on the
show we'll still see you on the show and
there's a little bit a little bit where
do things stand with him and them now
he's only Alana's father and that's I
want to set that record straight that's
the only Alana's father so the he try to
be like the father of the year
quote-unquote but you know he's got a
lot of growing up to do and a lot to
prove to her because the only calls are
like one someone that he hasn't seen her
and God knows win well this is such a
hot topic right now is women who have
had to deal with abuse and who have
tried to get out of situations what did
he I mean I don't know how much you want
to get into it but we saw him like you
said go after her on the reunion I
believe yes I said I mean her
is his fault her the Kira I with the
show when here
you know I mean there was several you
know scars you know hitting beating I'm
saying and dis emotional and it's been
hard and so for her all that anger just
like came out and it was worse than what
was actually showed on TV and that was a
mild version and it just gets worse so
does she speak to him now pumpkin no
does Alana speak to him
I mean once a month okay and I mean
authorities had to be involved I know
you probably unfortunately I've kind of
just kind of swept it and let it kind of
dissolve itself and now Alana's became
to a point now that she's can make her
own decisions so we're just working at
day by day day by day okay um Timothy
wants to know would you ever do we're
pivoting here but would you ever do
Dancing with the Stars
um a lot of people ask that and I ain't
got no rhythm like that no more so I
don't know about it's been talked about
but you know the rumors about it but
like I say there's a lot of rumors about
a lot of things that I don't even know
about I'm like God thank you for letting
me know that I was gonna do that so it
would not be would it be a no for you or
would you consider I'm not all about
getting heals and I look so good now you
got this new body hit that dance floor I
think it sounds like a maybe I don't
know let me do a quick little rapid-fire
with you after everything you've done
with the body with the transformation
your favorite body part now my arms how
come because I can actually wear a tank
top for the first time in my and in
years that's a milestone
that's awesome feel good about it what
has been the biggest surprise for you
post-surgery the thing you didn't expect
post-surgery
is probably not being able to see the
scars because I mean this car is you
can't really like - Wow
what about any splurge you gave yourself
post-surgery or like I did all this I'm
gonna reward myself did you buy yourself
any new clothes new clothes yes
how much did you spend probably a good
like 1,500 no I'm not even a 20,000
what about one thing that maybe you
would have done differently and the
whole surgery process anything moved and
there was anything that I would change
because I wanted it all I wanted it all
for myself and to make me feel good yeah
hardest moment since the surgery hardest
moment since the surgery keeping it off
and maintaining just all those moments
what about one body part you're still
working on your like I still work this
out my how do you say my legs my thighs
got anybody get my thighs done okay so
you're hitting the gym for those I mean
any specific workouts you do no not
really
okay just all-around I know you're your
trainer he really stays on you we love
watching him on the show I also want to
ask you you know you have been through
like we've talked about these up tune
ups and downs and relationships what do
you think your girls have learned from
your relationships don't take no BS off
of nobody because don't stay in a
relationship because you feel like you
have to you know you got to be happy for
and foremost don't stay with something
because the kids don't don't don't stay
in an unhappy relationship and that's
what more so I'm a victim of that
there's a lot of women and a lot of men
out there that are victims that and I
just kind of want to take an approach
now to be like okay kind of like speak
and like make kind of like there may be
a group or something that can actually
support people and actually make them
become healthy and say okay I can stand
up and I can leave I can do it myself
yeah do you think you stayed with sugar
bear too long definitely yeah have the
girls ever I mean have you ever like
talked about I don't know I don't know
what kind of conversations you have with
them but since they've been through so
much have they done any like counselling
seen anybody yeah pumpkin did for a long
long time and so like I said I mean
outside of that I mean we're very open
family so we talked a lot about what
goes on and stuff yeah do you see sugar
bear being in their lives in the future
on the show in the future from here
Kaitlyn wants to know she's making this
comment on YouTube mama June what about
any diets you are doing right now or
favorite healthy meals you share
anything that's a good go-to um for me
my go-to
is it's not really I wouldn't say
healthy but like I love like the veggie
chips and the veggie straws and stuff I
know it's not like healthy but it's
better than Thai to choose if you're
gonna snack make it a veggie chip what
about something you still let yourself
splurge on like a cheat day meal you
know I have to say
Nicolay no one can resist chick-fil-a
what about things that maybe you wish
you had done differently you said
nothing about the surgery but anything
you wish you'd done differently with
Anna or your other daughters in terms of
everything you've been through I have to
say that I wish things would have been
different maybe like for Anna you know
what I mean but you know life is what
you make your life is what it is and if
you two to get about too quick to have
regrets and think about your past and
you got to keep my boyfriend shows me a
good thing
quit don't ever look back because your
trip yourself up moving forward hmm I
like that alright he's teaching you I
like this guy
it's good to be with somebody who makes
you think about life differently
what about advice that you might give
Alana or pumpkin or your other daughters
about dating what do you tell them just
about dating um don't rush into things
too fast don't stay with the guy just
because you think you have to and also
find your happy medium like you don't
saying I love the fact that I mean a
boyfriend don't argue that much you know
I'm saying and it's like you know don't
don't sell yourself short don't think
you have to be with somebody you don't
you know say you don't have to be Alana
is a lot of 12 yes
is she dating anybody yet no no not yet
what are the rule what are your rules on
it um I don't really have any rules but
she's not a dating no she thinks that
she's dating this little boys like still
like sweating her you know I mean but
now when do you think first date will
happen like do you have a teenage when
you say no yeah whatever happens happen
um heating from YouTube says how are you
in Jennifer right now um I don't told
her I don't talk to that
I feel like that drama training stay on
their track always an entree sugar bear
is or Jennifer is she wears wide sugar
bears new wife okay yes cuz we see her
on the show a little bit yes yes so you
just don't talk to her keep things easy
stay off the drama train um what about
what you think that the audience's
biggest reaction is going to be to this
season you said emotional rollercoaster
what will they have the strongest
reaction to um I think another pumpkin
coming in swirl because I don't think
the world is ready for another point in
I promise you that in me actually
falling in love I think the fans are
gonna love that for once and
once in many many years mama June is
happy you are happy very well I love
that I think that's a solid note for us
to end on from not too hot premiering
tonight on WE tv 9:00 8:00 central and I
don't know if you can tease it for us
but I mean would you do a season three
um whatever happens happens and if they
offer it up fine if they don't then I
step back out the light and I appreciate
everything that was handed to me awesome
well you guys I know mama June loves you
loves the fans thank you so much for
watching with et live you want to say
anything to the fans I just want to say
thank you y'all can actually join me
tonight on live on Twitter oh mama June
underscore boo boo I will be live
tweeting there and then in a little bit
I'll be going Facebook allowed myself to
actually talk to y'all and get some
questions okay thanks so much for
watching everybody have a great weekend
and make sure to LIKE ET on Facebook
follow us on YouTube and social media
for more great interviews like this one
here Thanks thank you
[Music]
you